so valenciunas and now a steal by kyle  [Applause]  have fun grizzly have some fun  oh my goodness grizzlies have turned it  up  to 11 here in the quarter  and they lead it by 21.  i mean their level of play john morant  got it started with his attacks of the  basket  and then here great defense again and  why not  get a little funky with it  for kyle anderson his second steal of  the game  we were talking at halftime set  whichever one of these teams settles in  on the defensive side  would be able to take control well the  grizzlies came out of the locker room  with a defensive mindset and an attack  mindset on the offensive end  which has led to them being able to push  this lead out  to 21 from three at the half  the reaction to the bench and one of the  earlier angles  is just  wow they are just having fun they are  they are having fun and that's  that's what fun and execution leads to  wins